foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
God
how you doing people what's going on we
cold opened you there with some sports
uh because Lionel Messi who is arguably
the greatest soccer player of all time
Brock you're saying absolutely the
greatest soccer player of all time who
played most of his career in Europe for
Barcelona won the World Cup last year uh
he is now here in Miami in the Free
State of Florida and that was his first
game yesterday and as you can see uh he
won it for him not bad I don't know that
those pink uniforms had anything to do
with Barbie but Barbie has apparently
taken over the entire world I am a grown
adult so I have not seen the Barbie the
Barbie movie although I did watch Flash
Gordon with the kids over the weekend so
that's how I roll uh interestingly David
Beckham happens to own the Miami team
did you know that anywho uh that's going
to sort of set us up the realignment of
things people moving to places where
freedom is all that good stuff is going
to set us up for the show if you don't
know what you're watching you're
watching the Reuben report I'm Dave
Rubin it's July 24th 2023 we're live
streaming on Rumble locals and YouTube
Share And subscribe if you have not
already post game show at
reubenreport.locals.com after the show
and as you are keenly aware ladies and
gentlemen this is my last week on the
grid we are rolling into August so
Thursday will actually be our last show
we are doing a Miami meet up that night
with the locals community so you can
join the locals Community if you want to
join us for some uh some drinks and some
food and some good times in a sweltering
it's rather warm uh in August to Late
July August in uh in Miami but that's
all right if you want to join us Ruben
report.locals.com and uh and then I'm
off the grid till August 23rd I come
back in Milwaukee
at the big first Republican debate we
got Nikki Haley's going to join us
Governor DeSantis is going to join us
we're working on a couple of the other
candidates and it's going to be a big
setup I'll come back having no idea
what's going on for a couple weeks get
right to it debate all that good stuff
and I thought what we would talk about
today would be this sort of realignment
that I'm always talking about and and
the the mid-range people the people that
are maybe between say uh you know the
Bill Maher RFK types and then let's say
the Jordan Peterson Dave Rubin types
that there is this group of people who
are roughly trying trying to make sense
of some of this stuff and yesterday if
you didn't see it last night actually on
the Bill Maher podcast Club random uh
Jordan Peterson sat down with Bill for
about an hour and 45 minutes we're going
to show you a couple clips and then kind
of relate that to all of the
realignments that are happening because
Ron DeSantis was on Russell Brand's show
a couple day a couple days ago vivec was
on the all-in podcast which is mostly
Democrats except for David sacks so a
whole bunch of people are trying to
piece this thing together maybe we all
don't have the same candidate maybe we
all don't feel exactly the same way
about abortion this or that or the other
thing but we are all realizing that uh
this experiment is pretty good and we
would like it to continue so that's what
we're doing today let me talk to you
about my Patriot Supply and then we will
get to it guys as you know our world can
change in a moment's notice we're
currently on the brink of economic
collapse and it is scary but if you
don't think you need emergency food
right now wait a day a and see what
happens just don't wait too long because
as I speak prepare with reuben.com is
offering a huge discount on their
best-selling three-month emergency food
kit for a limited time you'll save 25
percent per kit that's the biggest
discount they offer but it doesn't come
along every day and it won't last so do
yourself a favor and grab your 25
discount on each three-month emergency
food kit you need it includes delicious
breakfasts lunches dinners and more
providing over 2 000 calories every day
get at least one kit per person in your
family grab your 25 discount today
before this offer expires you get fast
and free shipping too go to prepare with
reuben.com or you may regret it prepare
with reuben.com
and now back to me okay so these new
alignments they're a happening they're
happening publicly they're happening in
all of our personal lives we're
realizing hey we've got to get out of
this as I always call it endless descent
to hell right this is a problem so
anyway I was elated to see last night
that Jordan Peterson sat down with Bill
Maher and Jordan this was about 40
minutes in it took them about a half
hour it was actually very similar to
when I sat down with Bill where for the
first half hour we're kind of feeling
each other out like you kind of got to
get the vibe what's going on here maybe
we disagree on some stuff oh no but then
about 40 minutes in they started they
started locking in locking in and then
it got really kind of uh thoughtful and
interesting after that Jordan actually
posed Bill a question he uh asked him
when does the left go too far
could ask you a question that I've I've
asked like 40 Democrat senators and
congressmen and Robert F Kennedy by the
way recently this question it's a very
hard question and I don't ask it just
you know to cause trouble I'm actually
curious I am ready
when do you think the left goes too far
may I use my lifeline yeah absolutely
absolutely call the people who know who
know okay
um what I mean you mean they haven't
already well but how do you know like
what Trump gets reelected that's when
you know what would you regard as
behavior on the left that's unacceptable
from the perspective of someone who's
essentially liberal how long have you
gone I mean the theme I've been trying
to promulgate as much as I can the last
five years partly just in self-defense
of people who say say I've changed I
have not is that wokeness
is not something that expands on
liberalism it's something that undoes it
and I think you are on the same page
generally so they completely invert it
and then they get mad at us for somehow
we're conservatives no no we're not
conservatives you're just not what
Liberals are you're doing a different
thing which is fine we're allowed to do
our thing but you can't do this whole
different thing and then take the term
that used to apply but doesn't apply
anymore okay so Jordan who's been on
this Quest and as he said he's talked to
like 50 Big Time Democrats he was really
working to see if there was any
political will within the Democrat Party
to push the radicals out and
unfortunately I think he has found that
that will does not exist that the entire
thing has been just sort of rotted from
the inside he says to to Bill well what
do you see as those excesses now it's
obvious what Bill sees and I always give
credit for as much as I criticize bill I
give credit where credit is due and he's
always going after them on gender and
race and all of those things it's
interesting this idea of I I didn't
change which is something that bill
always says and it's funny because you
would think like for a liberal atheist
the idea of not changing wouldn't
necessarily be something that you'd be
kind of proud of right like you'd be
like Oh I'm the thoughtful one I can
change along the times I would say
that's a little more in line What I've
Done where I've sort of found common
cause with conservatives that I might
have some differences with but in
essence regardless of that bill is
actually sort of doing that with Jordan
that's why he's sitting down with those
people and he was very he was very
obvious how much he respects the guy and
everything else but Jordan was asking
the question because he wanted to see in
essence well Bill what makes you still
vote for these people
let's move on to the next clip because
you'll see how we link all these
together because Jordan starts talking
about how this really isn't we're always
focused on politics right that's why I'm
always veering in and out of the little
racehorse politics some days and then
the cultural stuff in other days that
this isn't necessarily just a political
battle it's actually a cultural battle
so there's a line of research that's
been developing I guess over the last
six or seven years that I think is very
relevant to this and because I've I've
been thinking more and more thoroughly
that the culture war is actually not a
political battle at all that the
political battle is a facade for the
actual battle and there's a very high
correlation between
the dark tetrad personality traits and
left-wing authoritarianism
so so that's why I think it's not
fundamentally political is that what's
happening is that there's a small
minority of people who are very
manipulative who use compassion as a
camouflage and then people who are
generally and genuinely uh compassionate
they can be manipulated easily and so
and that's not that's why you're seeing
that's part of the reason you're seeing
this deviation deviation from more
Classical liberalism there's no better
camouflage for someone who's truly dark
than compassion right right right
so I love that clip because it's Jordan
at his best explaining a very deep
complex idea to Bill who you can see
he's getting it at the end the way he
says right right so what's going on here
is that the the people who are really
kind of screwy and Jordan goes into uh
all of the psychological conditions that
can lead to all of that right that their
behavior online and the anonymity that
uh online life affords is actually being
weaponized against the people who are
genuinely compassionate so the Liberals
all your liberal friends who are
watching this who are just the normal
liberals the old school classical
liberals who put tolerance at the top of
that hierarchy they have been abused and
manipulated by the activist base and the
activist base again because it uses the
cover of anonymity you have this crazy
force that nobody seems to be able to
stop and then what Jordan's saying is
then our politicians are really just a
facade for what the real fight is about
there's a real fight that's going on
within all of us our behavior is how
we're all reacting to reality as it's
now given to us by algorithms and a
whole bunch more and the politicians
just sort of behave within that they're
just reacting to it but they're not the
drivers of all of this stuff which I I
was glad to see Bill kind of like
picking up on that sort of that notion
there was one other nice moment I want
to throw to here which uh was Bill just
telling Jordan how happy he was that he
was back and that there is this group of
people trying to make sense of some of
this stuff I can't tell you how great it
is to have you back well thank you I
mean honestly there was a lot of people
who when you were down and out were very
sad that like oh man that is one guy on
the team and our team is not that big
yeah that we cannot afford to lose you
know so to have you come back and be so
on it and looking good and and funny and
you know Brave as always
man that is
so what is this team is the question
right what is aligning these people with
each other I would say for the most part
with guys like Bill Maher and Jordan
Peterson it's free speech it's it's
Classical liberalism when it's able to
be applied they if you watch the whole
interview they get into Jordan basically
gets into why he thinks the classical
liberal experiment failed that in rough
times it just doesn't really sort of
operate in a functional way but let's
just set that aside for now maybe we'll
get to it another Point
um but this this team is interesting to
me because you've got guys like Bill
Maher and guys like Russell Brand so
Bill let's say is an old school liberal
Russell would be thought of as more of a
leftist then you've got Jordan Peterson
who now is thought solidly as a
conservative works with Ben Shapiro and
Dennis Prager who certainly are
conservatives but we're all kind of
talking to each other there's something
interesting there Bill had Russell Brand
on the show not too long ago and said
the same thing to him
essentially a competitor to YouTube
which has made its raison d'etre
non-censorship that has been taken up
initially by a lot of right uh like
you'd have to say a right-wing uh voices
uh but is doesn't have any skin in the
game with regard to like all the kind of
content that is put out except for that
you continue to own your content and you
know you can say what you want you can
talk about what you want and like for me
like freedom of speech doesn't mean
freedom of speech doesn't condemn and
criticize people it means freedom of
speech to attack establishment and look
for ways to bring people together baby
Rubin Dave rubin's on there yeah I know
Dave's been on this and his company
though but they've owned I believe
locals which is the sort of membership
aspect of Rumble which is essentially
like YouTube he's been here love love I
love him yeah he's a great guy yeah and
we don't agree politically no but we
laugh about it it's it's it's yeah and
the prayers the problem with Where We
Are
media wise as especially Free Speech you
know as Comics we adore free speech I
it's it's my life blood I couldn't be
there I'm so grateful to the people who
came before me who were Martyrs for free
speech you know there was no doubt in my
mind who the champions of free speech
were and and also the threat and the
threat was all on the right yeah and the
Champions were on the left and that's
not how I feel now so when people say
like oh why are you harder on the left
well that's one of the big reasons I
just mentioned Lenny Bruce so I'm going
to say that that's a sign from the
universe and by the way Dave rubin's
always trying to convince me about the
universe which I find amusing but um I'm
going to pretend there's such a thing is
the universe
and say that uh Lenny Bruce you know he
forgot to like be an Entertainer because
he was so passionate right I don't want
that to happen to you I don't think it
will it never has you proved that like
not just here but on real time today was
just like
you know you bring him in
and just uh that's you know I don't know
why I'm anointing myself as the person
to give you advice you probably don't
need okay I know we're going heavy on
Bill here but I think you see what I'm
painting for you that this Alliance if
you were to take guys like Bill Maher
Russell Brand
JFK Jr who's in the mix oh sorry RFK
Junior who's in the mix with these guys
Jordan Peterson
say Ron DeSantis we'll get to him in
just a second
throw a little Dave Rubin sprinkle a
little Dave Rubin on top like what is
that what is that politically are these
are these all conservatives are they all
liberals like but there's something
there that is a little closer to the
truth than any of the nonsense we are
being pushed so why did I throw
desantis's name and they're not just
because I'm a Florida man but also
because uh Governor DeSantis went on
Russell Brand's podcast on Friday again
you've got
what most would say is the most
conservative Red State Governor in
America and Lefty Russell Brand and they
have common cause
Ron when I was in Florida recently I was
struck by the amount of pride that
Floridians have in their state you
appear to be universally endorsed by the
population of Florida I did stand-up
comedy there a lot of my stand-up was
talking about measures taken in the
pandemic where I live in the UK and the
abroad and
I would say spookily ubiquitous response
to the pandemic in most places in the
world except one might contest in
Florida I'm sure that that the center of
State pride that Floridians have is a
source of great joy to you I wonder how
you came to the position of confidence
in taking a stance that was antithetic
antithetical to the sales taken
elsewhere in America
well I'm glad you noticed that I was
born and raised in Florida and while
I've always loved the state we didn't
have the same type of Pride growing up
that say people in Texas have about
Texas and yet in the last few years
particularly since I've been Governor
we've developed that pride and I think a
lot of it's rooted in the fact that we
told like people like fauci to take a
hike during covid uh we were going to do
it our way we were going to be the free
state of Florida and obviously that
meant people had a right to work right
to operate businesses kids needed to be
in school we fought back against
mandates both in terms of not letting
local governments impose Mass mandates
not letting government or business
impose coveted vaccine mandates so in
every step of the way we were really
leading okay again you've got Lefty like
Lefty Lefty Russell Brand and Ron
DeSantis agreeing on what freedom is now
they might disagree in other ways on
what the government's supposed to do
related to certain things say the
environment whatever it might be but
again this wide swath of people Russell
Brand Bill Maher over here Jordan
Peterson Ron DeSantis over here and and
I would say the best uh the vast wide
swath of Americans are right in between
those things and that's what we need to
be drawing more people too right it's
not to change anyone's religious beliefs
it's not to change it's actually not to
change anyone's mind on anything other
than to understand there's a there's a
country of about 350 million people here
we've done it pretty damn well for 200
plus years and we're on the precipice of
throwing it away unless we're able to
have these conversations and fight the
real problem which right now the real
problem is the swamp whether it's just
purely the DC swamp or it's the media
Elite corporate press That's the swamp
and Russell and the governor talked
about that as well you still have people
today fouchy and the like they think
that what they did was right they think
that these lockdowns worked and so my
fear is if this happens in the future a
lot of these people are going to want to
do the same thing again so one of the
things I pledged as president and I
think I'm the only one running on the
Republican side who will be willing to
do this we're going to bring a reckoning
to this health bureaucracy and this
medical swamp because these agencies
like CDC nihfda they failed the American
people they become corrupted and they
did a lot of damage with these
unscientific anti-freedom policies well
that's pretty heartening to hear in
retrospect to your stance increasingly
seems to have been the correct one and
that's interesting and exciting in fact
to hear you talk about a reckoning
interesting because if you listen to my
interview with RFK Jr from a couple
weeks ago if you've listened to
virtually anything that RFK Jr who's the
Renegade Democrat right now he sounds an
awful lot like the governor of Florida
the Republican governor of Florida again
there is a lane for all of these people
we got to figure out what that looks
like I'll even go further now and show
you how some of this realignment is
happening uh because Vivek ramaswamy and
I've had some issues with vivec I
basically like him he's I think he's
been a little uh some of his stuff with
the sad that seems a bit much like
there's some coordination with Trump
okay fine that's just that's just
internal politics but he went on the
all-in podcast now the all-in podcast
three of the hosts are pretty much
Democrats I think they call themselves
Democrats and then you've got David
sacks who is the more conservative uh of
all of them and they started talking
about populism and why it's the movement
populism if that's the thing I'm talking
about right now that's bringing all of
these people together
what you call populism I don't
excuse me I don't I don't like this I
mean by the way just to be clear I think
that it's just imprecise he's a rapper
that tries to catch too many things and
it doesn't catch any of them enough so
yeah yeah don't you think of what you're
calling populism is actually a failure
of our Elites isn't that what's going on
we saw during covid that all the health
authorities did a horrible job the CDC
and the NIH it turns out they were
funding function research which may have
caused kovid in the first place they
were doing experiments on bat viruses
almost certainly did cause yeah exactly
so
you know we keep finding out that the
elites are supposed to be running the
country and running these institutions
are doing an absolutely horrible job
that's what the reaction is against then
people come along and label up populism
and say it's going to lead to Fascism
it's like come on that is a way of
protecting the people in power from
accountability for the horrible job
they're doing it's well said absolutely
okay so that was obviously more sax than
Vivek but sax lays it out perfectly what
the problem is and how they try to scare
you into ever finding a solution I
credit vivec for sitting down with these
guys this is the point this is the point
again he fits within that lane as well
now let's go a little bit more to what
vivec was laying out as the alternative
Vision to all the nonsense we've been
dealing with
this thing that I'm calling woke is
turning into which is a more broader
kind of
social psychological issue that we're
all grappling with right how it's now
leeched its way into politics it's
leached its way into nonprofits it's
leached its way
into Corporate America
into for-profits into the military into
government Etc obviously since that was
published it has now become this hot
term that has different meaning for
different people and it can be pretty
exciting in terms of
yeah I appreciate you saying that Dave
because my net prescription is actually
we dilute not just wokeism I mean that's
just part of the story We dilute secular
religions the rise of secular religion
right and I don't call them even
religions because the religion is
withstood the test of time occult has
not but the rise of modern secular
occults we dilute them to irrelevance by
filling that void with an alternative
vision and so you know if one political
Camp might offer race and gender and
sexuality and climate as a prescription
for the void
I think we're conservatives fall badly
short is by simply being anti those
things without actually offering an
alternative vision of our own and I am
aiming certainly to do that in this case
and gender and these kind of things what
would be your uh you know qualities or
things to focus on
so let's do like a little face off right
individual we're talking about race
gender sexuality climate
I pair them up against
individual family Nation God okay all
right so there's something there right
it makes sense individuals family God
Nation these are these are all the ideas
that built this thing this thing which
again for 250-ish years has worked
really well and it's only in the last
decade that we've really seen it kind of
grind into what this cultural chaos that
we're all dealing with right now so now
if you take this wide swath again you
take a bunch of guys who are Democrats
on that show except for David sacks
sitting down with vivec an absolute
conservative Russell Brand sitting down
Russell Brand Lefty sitting down with
DeSantis opposite ends of the spectrum
but both believe in Freedom maybe they
believe a little bit differently on how
to get there that's usually what it's
about Peterson and Mar like Mar telling
Peterson man I'm so happy you're back
it's like you guys are definitely going
to vote in different ways and that's
that's a problem right maybe that's why
we need some more choices but I would
say at this point I've Illustrated what
this thing is right so you're with me
let's hope hopefully you're roughly with
me that there's this this Lane that we
can kind of all get in right and it's
not fully based on politics it's
culturally anti-woke we all get that but
but who is the opposition to this thing
like where is it really coming from when
we talk about the elites and the
corporations and everything else well
now I'd like to show you a video that I
saw on Twitter uh that somebody splice
together of Disney the Disney
corporation that that Rhonda said this
guy was smacking around not too long ago
then verse now and I think you'll sort
of capture how we lose control of our
own culture over time take a look
stands for us as a group of people we
of each other and time of need this
country was built on slavery which means
slaves built this country the flag means
everything to me it means life it means
freedom it also means unity and it means
love we the descendants of slaves in
America have earned reparations for
their suffering and continue to earn
reparations every moment we spend
submerged in the systemic Prejudice
racism and white supremacy all the flags
you know you ride down the street and it
makes you feel connected like we're in
this together
which means slaves
so now do you see what we're all railing
against uh Connor just made a just made
a great point which is the clips of that
several of those clips are from the show
Proud Family which tells you so the new
ones and the old ones so in the old days
Proud Family same show uh when it was
real people uh it was you know America's
good and oh it unites us and then now
became an animated show and look what
they're talking about so you see how we
lose control of these things and they
aim it at children because they're going
for the generations whose minds are
malleable who they can basically turn
them into walking zombies of woke lunacy
but it continues this is super
interesting as you may know they're
remaking Disney is remaking Snow White
this video is actually from September of
22 the actress who will be playing Snow
White her name is Rachel zegler she was
interviewed with Wonder Woman what's
Wonder Woman's name Gal Gadot on a red
carpet and they were asking her about
this new what this new character is
going to be like
you said you were bringing a Modern Edge
to it on stage what do you mean by that
I just mean that it's no longer 1937 and
we absolutely absolutely wrote a snow
white that is
going to be safe for The Prince and
she's not gonna be dreaming about true
love she's dreaming about becoming the
leader she knows she can be and the
leader that her late father told her
that she could be if she was Fearless
Fair Brave and true and so it's just a
really incredible story for I think
young people everywhere to see
themselves in Snow White is running for
president
I'm launching my campaign and yeah okay
so you may be watching that and go well
there's nothing really wrong with that
there's no nothing wrong with a girl
thinking that she can go be fearless and
lead the world and all those things and
of course you are right so what's the
problem well what do you have to do you
got to peel that layer and then just
look a little bit deeper and then you
figure out what's wrong with it there is
nothing wrong with the story in the
first place the idea that this girl met
the prince accomplished her dreams fell
in love blah blah blah so instead of
destroying everything that is old
destroying Snow White but we saw that
the Seven Dwarfs are no longer dwarfs
you got rapey and Dopey and and
angry and all the rest of them instead
of destroying everything from the past
which the woke are extremely good at
doing how about you just create a new
story why didn't Disney just create a
new story with a great strong
interesting female lead and and make it
everything that the actress would like
it to be if that if that's the right way
to go about doing it by the way you can
make stories like that and you can make
stories about a traditional princess
etc etc but they try to destroy
everything and then once all of the
stuff all of our stories you Rampage
through the the biblical stories you
Rampage through all of our cultural
stories whether it's Disney movies or
Star Wars or whatever any of the stuff
that can bring any of us together music
we'll get to that in just a moment once
you destroy all of that well then we
have nothing else that brings us
together and then you wonder why
everybody's looking at everybody going
oh you're black you're gay ah problem
it's a problem so let's get to this
other thing that's going on as relate as
this relates to culture uh in this case
music so you may have heard the whole
brouhaha about country star Jason Aldean
uh he well let me read this this long
tweet
that'll explain what's going on the
whole thing's so stupid here we go uh in
the past 24 hours I have been accused of
releasing a pro-lynching song a song
that has been out since May and was
subject to the comparison that I direct
quote was not too pleased with the
Nationwide BLM protest these references
are not only meritless but dangerous
there is not a single lyric in the song
that references race or points to it and
there isn't a single video clip that
isn't real news footage and while I can
try and respect others to have their own
interpretation of a song with music this
one goes too far as so many pointed out
I was present at Route 91 where so many
lost their lives and our community
recently suffered another heartbreaking
tragedy no one including me wants to
continue to see senseless headlines or
families ripped apart try that in a
small town for me
refers to the feeling of a community
that I had growing up where we took care
of our neighbors regardless of
differences of background or belief
because they were our neighbors and that
was above any differences my political
views have never my political views have
never been something I've hidden from
and I know that a lot of us in this
country don't agree on how we get back
to a sense of normalcy where we at least
go a day without a headline that keeps
us up at night but the desire for it too
but the desire for it too that's what
this song is about okay so in essence
the guy puts out a song back in May
nobody cared about it for months or it
was doing perfectly fine right like it
was doing just fine but nobody thought
of it as controversial then out of
nowhere it becomes the super
controversial thing and he's a racist
and he should be canceled and all of
this other craziness and listen to the
way the main it's very obvious this guy
is not a racist right we've been through
this guys right like rinse and repeat
we've been through this before someone
says something that is roughly true you
get told you're a racist and a
misogynist then a trans woman a
homophobe and everything else but watch
the way the mainstream media is treating
this story here are the well put up the
warning here are the crazy women at the
view and here's Whoopi and no Whoopi
doesn't even know what she's watch the
way she's reading this thing she doesn't
even know what she's saying or why she's
outraged but she'll say it
so country singer Jason Aldean is
getting backlash for the video of his
song not in a small town which critics
are saying is racist that lyrics racist
lyrics and images
Aldean says the songs about Unity listen
I listen you know there are lyrics in
the song and I think
you know he talks about life in a small
town and it's different you know and he
shows these images he's got uh folks
uh from the black lives matter movement
and he's talking about people taking
care of each other and I find it so
interesting that never occurred to Jason
or the writers that that's what these
folks were doing they were taking care
of the people in their town because they
didn't like what they saw just like you
talk about people taking care of each
other in small towns we do the same
thing in big towns you just have to
realize that when you make it about
black lives matter people kind of say
well are you are you
talk about black people what are you
talking about
man it's just such a damn shame because
I really did love her as an actress I
say it all the time right like ghost and
Sister Act and like all that stuff she
was so great she has no idea what she's
talking about she's never listened to
the song I just read the statement from
the guy also what is she talking about
that the people in essence she's saying
oh the people in the big cities who burn
down the cities it was because they were
taking care of their communities tell
that to the people at Foot Locker and
Pep Boys you know what I mean it's like
what it's just nonsense it's like pure
nonsense to pretend that he's racist
because he grew up in a place where they
took care of each other which is what we
should all want right it's why you
should move to a community that is
somewhat in line with your values it's
why Big City Life Is So frayed at the
moment because you have no because
people have no connection with each
other even when I lived in New York City
I lived in a you know small I don't know
five-story walk-up he had like three
other apartments on the same floor 10
years living in the same apartment
barely knew anybody like he'd say hi to
somebody maybe usually you ignore them
and I didn't know anyone's name it's
like I know all my neighbors names here
it's just different and it's and it's
reality but she's somehow framing it
somehow they were protecting their
Community by burning the whole thing
down and looting and taking all those
flat screen TVs and all that uh but
don't worry I don't want to be too harsh
on Whoopi because you know I've laid out
who I think the best and worst hosts of
The View are they're all bad uh but
Sunny Hosten
she's even worse and here she goes
and unfortunately this became the number
one
song on U.S iTunes we have a problem in
this country about race and the biggest
problem is we refuse to admit that it
exists well don't you think a lot of
this big city small town businesses
racist is about racism the cities have
more black people than the small towns
of course these people are so incredibly
stupid first off uh as Brock pointed out
to me saying something is number one on
iTunes is a completely ridiculous stat
because who's using iTunes to buy music
anymore I have not bought a song a
decade you got you guys are young kids
you're out there on the computer and
everything Daphne when's the last time
you bought a song bought ever have you
ever bought a song in your life 10 years
ago Connor 10 years ago Phoenix
10 years ago Brock
over 10 years ago nobody buys music
anymore you have Spotify you have apple
music whatever app you're using so the
idea that it's number one it doesn't
mean it's sold a ton and it certainly
doesn't mean that people were buying the
song because they're racist right like
it's just brainless and then Whoopi
again trying to just associate
everything to black people live in
cities and white people live in the
suburbs you know there are black Farmers
Whoopi uh joy
joy uh but well continue with joy well
here we go
but he has to understand that the big
cities are supporting the small towns 70
blue counties are responsible for 70
percent of America's economy the big
cities are really providing the things
that you have in these small towns you
should not be against big cities Joy
have you ever put food in that feed bag
because you know where the food comes it
doesn't come from the cities it comes
from those Suburban areas it comes from
the Farms it comes from those places
that you never go to right that's where
I used to live right two blocks away
from you on the upper west I I remember
Joy you think we were doing a lot of
farming over there it's so insane yes
there's a lot of economic activity
there's a lot of trade right that's
going on in the cities people are buying
a lot of crap in the cities that is true
but the if which one's going to go down
first and which one would survive zombie
apocalypse the aliens show up tomorrow
all hell is breaking loose the cities go
down immediately it's the people out
there in the suburbs who grow food for
themselves who have a little bit of land
who can protect themselves who aren't
reliant on the system you have
everything backwards you joyless Dullard
but it's the point is they're not just
going after people on the right now
let's link this to what I started the
show with when you watch people on The
View
they're not just going after people on
the right and they're not just going
after the perceived racists like Jason
Aldean who is not racist they're also
going after every moderate Democrat and
sometimes they're doing that in in the
most vicious possible way because they
represent the biggest threat right so
obviously you can see where I'm going
with this uh RFK Junior he's testified a
couple days ago on misinformation at
Congress and he talked about how the
Democrat Administration run by the
elderly man pretended to be President
Joe Biden has been treating him
was censored not just by the Democratic
Administration I was censored by the
Trump Administration
I was the first person censored by as
the chairman pointed out by the Biden
Administration two days after it came
into office YouTube
de-platform to me
I didn't talk about vaccines in that
speech I didn't talk about anything that
people it was a verboten subject
I just was talking about my campaign and
things the conversation
we ought to be happy with each other as
Americans
but I was shut down and that is why the
first amendment is important
debate and genial respectful debate is
the is the fertilizer it's the water
it's the sunlight for our democracy we
need to be talking to each other
ain't that beautiful and ain't that the
truth and they ain't that exactly what
Bill Maher was saying to Jordan Peterson
ain't that in essence what Russell Brand
was saying to Ron DeSantis and there are
certain people that are doing just that
and then the counter to that is what
they are doing on The View the counter
to that is what they are doing when
they're trying to cancel country singers
and everything else but I want to also
link this to how the corporate press not
just what you're seeing on TV but if
you're old school and you're reading a
newspaper or you're looking online at
the New York Times which used to be all
the News That's fit to print and now it
is just an absolute Pravda level
propaganda Outlet listen there was a
piece they were covering the RFK Junior
appearance at the Congress listen to
this line I saw this from Ashley
rinsberg who's been on the show before
who wrote a great book about how
terrible things are at the New York
Times listen to this line that was in an
actual this is not in an op-ed this is
in an actual article in the New York
Times about Free Speech despite the
theater the hearing raised thorny
questions about free speech in a
Democratic Society is misinformation
protected by the first amendment when is
it appropriate for the government to
seek to Tamp down on the spread of fall
so let's leave that up for just a second
Connor because I can answer it fairly
quickly is misinformation protected by
the First Amendment yes when is it
appropriate for the federal government
to seek to Tamp down on the spread of
falsehoods never see fixed it done guess
we could wrap it up today but that is
what that is the seed when RFK talks
about sunlight as the best disinfectant
right and be able to talk about things
and let's see how the truth can actually
set us free they're trying to they're
trying to actually starve the seed of
nutrition and of water they don't want
you to question anything because if you
start questioning anything you might
realize that the swamp and the Democrats
and all of these people are in it to
control you not to free you here is a
bit more from Democrats trying to censor
RFK at a censorship hearing
every statement that you just made about
me is inaccurate at one point you say
I'm anti-vaxx and that's a bad thing the
other thing the other moment you point
out that all my children are facts I
took flu vaccines for 20 years straight
I have never been to anti-facts these
are defamations and malignancies that
are used to censor me to prevent people
from listening to the actual things that
I'm saying trusting the experts is not a
function of science it's not a function
of democracy it's a function of religion
and totalitarianism and it does not make
for healthier population I move that we
would move into executive session
because Mr Kennedy has repeatedly made
Despicable anti-semitic and anti-asian
comments is it the custom of this
committee to censor viewpoints that we
disagree with from Witnesses
on the table this is an attempt to
censor a censorship hearing
the the
charges in this and and by the way
censorship is antithetical to our party
it was at it was appalling to my father
to my uncle to FDR Harry Truman the
Thomas Jefferson we have to stop trying
to destroy each other to marginalize to
vilify to Gaslight each other we have to
find that place inside of ourselves of
the light of empathy of compassion
man he's trying he's trying you think
it's easy to do what he's doing again
whether I agree with him or disagree
with him and in my interview we
disagreed on a bunch of stuff right we
disagree on affirmative action that was
very clear that's just one example but
you think it's easy to do what he's
doing to get up there and sit with these
people under oath and they lie about you
and they try to stop you from speaking
at a censorship hearing as in essence
all you're saying is can we talk about
these things can we question these
things just because pharmaceutical
companies say something or the NIH say
something that does not mean it is true
it does not mean in fact can we talk
about that and they trying to cut him
off they're trying to cut him off who
are the good guys and who are the bad
guys again put aside whoever you're
thinking of voting for next time around
put aside whether you usually vote
Republican or usually vote Democrat like
there is something else Brewing right
now and I I don't know exactly what we
do with it but if we can piece this
thing together it can become something
really really important and Powerful
that will trans send politics so let's
go a little bit more linking this all
together piecing this all together here
is RFK Jr on Lex Friedman's podcast
responding to a piece that Jordan
Peterson was talking about about uniting
and uh where we can go from here
let me ask you this a question from
Jordan Peterson that he asked uh when I
told him that I'm speaking with you
given everything you've said when does
the left go too far
I suppose he's referring to
cultural issues
identity politics
well you know
Jordan trying to get me to bad mouth the
laugh the whole time I was in I really
enjoyed my my uh my talk with him yeah
but he seemed to have that agenda where
he wanted me to you know say bad things
about the left and I just don't you know
that's not what my campaign is about I
want to do the opposite
oh I'm not going to bad mouth laugh they
try you know I was on a show this week
with David remnick from the New Yorker
and he tried to get me to bad mouth
Donald Trump and you know and Alex Jones
and a lot of other people just and and
aiding me to do it
and of course there's a lot of bad
things I can say about all those people
but it doesn't you know I'm trying to
find
I'm trying to find values that hold us
together and we can share in common
rather than to focus constantly on these
disputes and these issues that drive us
apart I really want to figure out ways
that you know what do these groups hold
in common that we can all
you know have a shared vision of what we
want this country to look like you know
it's interesting because I obviously
agree the whole purpose of today's show
was that I agree with the spirit of that
I actually think you have to do both I
get why RFK he doesn't want to just sit
there and lambast Trump left and right
and he also doesn't want to sit there
and lambast the left all day
I think you sort of have to do both or
we all everyone has different roles in
this and everything else right like I
tell you what I think for a living every
day so I'm talking about why it's crazy
what the corporate press is doing and
what AOC or the view or all those things
I think you do have to call that out and
then also at the same time show that
there are much bigger things that bring
us together that was the purpose of all
of this so it's not about it's not about
relentlessly hitting your political
opponent I would say it's about hitting
your cultural opponent right and and
sometimes that's a specific person just
saying something stupid like Sunny
Austin but more so it's attacking their
terrible ideas because if we can do that
if we can do that we can get over this
thing that we are stuck in it's still
it's murky to see that in the future but
I know we can get past it and now to go
full circle on today's program
how about one more from Bill and one
more from this Dave Rubin Guy this is
back in last September man almost a year
ago talking about just that
the bottom line is the fact that you and
I are have these differences and don't
it's like it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
I'm so glad you don't say that bill
predictably within the parameter yes of
two human beings the odd the odds that
two human beings would see everything
exactly the same way how pathetic and
annoying and ridiculous yeah and
ridiculous so the fact that you know we
both fall within the 30-yard line of
each side it's like it's how could you
expect more than that or even care that
it's not more than that or not love the
person
I
I hear you brother that's all like
that's all I can say about that I hear
you brother what I would like to do more
than anything else honestly I'd like to
shoot hoopsy at some point I I can't
tell you how I don't care about I don't
care what that I do believe in that I
don't care about the differences I know
you don't either I've said this before
on this podcast I'm going to say it
again since this whole thing started can
I take off my shoes already because then
I'd feel really at home killing it with
guys
I am so many guy friends yeah that I
didn't have before and I'm glad you're
one of them because uh this was super
fun but it's over now that's it
now I got it oh sorry Bill I have to get
on the plane and ring the bell
[Laughter]
you get it you got it
Phoenix I think we put together a fine
program today I'm very proud of all you
people in this room I think we made some
sense here and let's see if we can now I
don't know blueprint that sense across
disciplines across media across the
political divide I don't know what it
means exactly right like these people
will still end up voting in different
ways I accept that most likely Bill
Maher well Jordan Peterson's not a
citizen of the United States but if he
was like they'd probably vote in
opposite ways okay there's something to
think about there but you got it Russell
Brand also not a citizen of the United
States but I'm pretty sure if he was
here he would vote for Rhonda Santos
like but the voting part is not really
the thing there's something else I think
we're on it guys it's Monday which means
it's meme Monday over at the Reuben
report locals Community here's what I
put up this is the the Ukraine War uh
summed up quite
Ukraine just bashing its head over in
the U.S just helping it beat its head
relentlessly we had to cut the audio on
this one because it was copyrighted guys
we got a post game show for you right
now at
reubenreport.locals.com my full
interview with Liz wheeler is up is part
one up uh on the other platforms there
it'll be up this afternoon right
pull this up on locals pull us up oh
fills up everywhere Liz wheeler
everywhere uh we leave you with a little
we're not doing something funny on the
way out we're leaving you with just pure
wisdom and heartfelt Knowledge from JP
and we'll see everybody on the other
side ciao what's real matter it's like
okay that's one answer what's real what
matters is real because that's how you
act that's different than matter what's
the most real of what matters how about
pain why is it the most real try arguing
it away so pain is the fundamental
reality doesn't that lead to nihilism
and hopelessness yeah doesn't it lead to
a philosophy that's antithetical towards
being the most fundamental reality is
pain
yes is there anything more fundamental
than pain
really
if you're in pain
love and truth
that's what you got and you know if
they're more powerful than pain maybe
they're the most real things because if
you're a scientist a materialist think
well
the matter is the most real it's like
well you don't know what the matter is
when push comes to shove and it will
you'll find out what's most real
[Music]